on
alors qu'il a toujours voulu rentrer
dans la salle c'est le rêve de gosse
c'est un rêve de gosse est là qui va se
réaliser
je suis très heureux merci monsieur ce
tuner parce que ça c'est vraiment avec
plaisir alors moi ce que je voudrais
c'est montréal semble aimer mais du côté
des députés c'est-à-dire voir où est ce
qu'ils travaillent ouais ça des petits
murs dans des petites robes et voilà où
est ce qu'ils mangent ou est-ce qu'ils
dorment cccv de ce côté là qui
m'intéressent commence dès plats comment
ils se déplacent alors vous vous
déplacer en vélo vous bourrez en vélo
électrique à l'assemblée voilà des vélos
de l'assemblée ça c'est les vélos de
l'assemblée nationale y en a six qui
sont à disposition de débuter pour le
déplacement alors que le tourisme
[Musique]
est là donc là là et là moment d'émotion
c'est génial voilà regardez-le alors
allez c'est super l'assemblée nationale
le rapporteur général du budget qui
manque de se faire écraser
alors ça c'est le côté de la scène c'est
là où le travail réside le président
vincent et pierre richard ferrand
[Musique]
eh oui
donc vous venez en vélo tous les jours
est tous les jours hélas quand on arrive
là c'est la cour des chauffeurs sont des
chauffeurs d'avoir laissé la place à une
voiture alors là là c'est la grande cour
là c'est la grande cour à la grande cour
d'honneur je suis très donc le
gouvernement à riespach là d'accord et
donc qu'ils ont un cheminement convard
produit vous avez l'entrée de la salle s
[Musique]
et vous voilà arrivés à destination
comme je sais pas pourquoi ça me
rappelle un beau lifting versailles vous
allez savoir c'est très beau
ouais enfin la vitesse tav rendent dans
les allées oui mais sans tuer
alors là l'important c'est le
pied-à-terre le pied de huy pied-à-terre
avec classe et distinction alors montrez
moi voilà oh la la allez allez
[Musique]
vous pouvez mettre le vôtre ici gmail
tenir ici
on mange dans la prise et directement
hockey et on met les cannes à a et on
vient de 4,9 c'est compatible la tenue
de député parce que là vous êtes hors
vous êtes en costume en fait renforcé
mes costumes d'entre eux
pour pouvoir faire du vélo ou là-bas
sinon on à moi oui pantalon vous êtes
vous êtes très en forme à ce que vous
pensez que vos collègues devrait faire
pareil devrait faire plus il devrait
plus utiliser les vélos mais oui mais
plus c'est utiliser vélos puissent
utiliser les escaliers parce que on
parle souvent ici il ya des grands
discours sur le sport santé sur rai
ouais la mobilité du quotidien sourd je
les collèges mais pourquoi tu prends
l'ascenseur prend les escaliers puis
après on viendra parler sport santé vous
c'est pas le vélo tour de france voulait
pas être le premier du peloton
c'est pas mon état d'esprit quoi que
j'aime bien avoir le lido si ça m'arrive
de justo aussi encore parfois de faire
un peu la course ça permette de ruminer
alors s'alarmer de ruminer mon travail
des parlementaires ça me permet aussi de
me balader à des endroits où sinon je
passerais pas dans ma circonscription et
des souvent je me dis allez chez le
singe est passée par là à vélo ça me
permet de voir puisque ben voilà quelle
est l'ambiance du quartier vous le savez
vous la sentez quand vous passez en vélo
alors j'aimerais bien qu'on voit ça la
station de réparation ouais bah ça vous
en trouvez de plus en plus partout en
france à strasbourg sedan avec 100 libre
service comme ça
ah ah qu'est-ce que se fixe alors oui
d'accord mais sa cible et le bleu à mal
si vous allez crever voilà d'accord puis
après ça c'est pour resserrer les
boulons métaphore politique et ben merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci de la visite
avec plaisir bastille nation
je
bonjour madame la vice présidence
changement merci de nous accueillir vous
en prie alors ici on est dans la salle
la fameuse salle des quatre colonnes
puis c'est la salle médiatique par
excellence puisque lorsque nous sortons
de l'hémicycle nous passons fatalement
par cette salle mais surtout le
principal intérêt pour les députés c'est
évidemment la présence de la presse
c'est ça c'est la salle où la presse
attend les députés oui souvent
fébrilement à la sortie
fébrilité parfois partagées par les
députés eux mêmes oui mais que les rares
qui sont impatients de d'être arrêté
parce que c'est un film de notoriété
vous comprenez si vous êtes arrêté par
un les journalistes c'est que vous êtes
une personnalité en vue aurait si vous
êtes à peine regarder quand vous passez
c'est que vraiment c'est la salle des
vanités quoi quand on ne veut pas parler
parce qu'il ya des stratégies lorsque
l'on pressent qu'on va être interrogé
sur un sujet embarrassant et qu'on ne
veut pas parler ce qui est souvent ce
qui arrive ce qui est qu'on veut
absolument qu'on est obligé de passer
par cette salle on est au téléphone
comprenez ça c'est une stratégie lucide
ah bon on passe on fait ce genre gelé je
peux pas vous parler
alors j'aimerais qu'on parle j'aimerais
que vous nous parler de ce fameux ce
canapé de ce canapé c'est un canapé
assez unique en son genre je pense
qu'ils symbolisent aussi bien la pièce
et puis c'est le canapé pour le mans le
plus filmé de france oui certainement je
vais essayer demain soir pour voir si si
voilà
c'est aussi
un canapé qui peut être utile à la
conversation alors ça me rappelle sa les
canapés et fauteuils et de bons jeux
courtoisie effective qui sont s comme ça
et qui permet de discuter 100 ans en
voilà sans se regarder
alors docteur un docteur j'ai un
problème je rêve de l'assemblée alors ça
vous savez mon cher c'est un rêve
partagé par beaucoup surtout en ces
périodes de pré électorale ouais mais si
vous avez des ambitions à la matière il
va falloir que vous franchissez le
rubicon quitté la sphère médiatique pour
la sphère politique qui réfléchissent et
bien qui n'est finalement pas la chance
c'est un chemin sans retour
très très confortable un canal +
a retrouvé oui parce qu'il est
confortable mais pas moi je trouve que
les fauteuils à l'assemblée nationale ne
brille pas vrai véritablement par
l'heureux leur confort les sièges sur
lesquels
nous sommes dans l'hémicycle sont très
étroits il ya peu d'espacé alors le
fauteuil du perchoir c'est le summum de
l'inconfort un peu oui parce que c'est
une pièce historique vous comprenez donc
on ne peut pas y toucher
bonjour monsieur le corps son bonjour
c'est très impressionnant d'être là
c'est très grand mais ça ne paraît pas
très grand oui donc c'est assez bien
équilibré c'est ce demi cercle et puis
on croit que c'est la lumière naturelle
mais je crois que ça n'est pas la
lumière du grand non non non parce que
vous avez un éclairage zénithal et
pendant longtemps d'ailleurs quand il y
avait des grands orages
dans un temps ça nous tomber dessus
c'est vrai oui c'était entièrement
réparé etc
on monte
quand on arrive ici vous voyez on règle
en fonction de votre hauteur de façon à
ce que les micros soient à bonne hauteur
par rapport à votre bouche et vous avez
devant vous ce petit carré où on voit le
temps qu'ils progressent et vers la fin
le président avec sa règle tape un peu
ici dans mon cher collègue
alors ça veut dire dépêchez vous et vous
avez un petit truc qui s'allument
normalement voilà rouge ça veut dire
qu'ils étendent
mignotte puis il ya la petite cloche
chez le président
chers collègues un peu de calme voilà
[Musique]
il ya aussi tout un tas de choses qui
sont autorisés interdit qu'il ya des
usages très très précis dans l'hémicycle
regardez ce que vos collègues en dise
c'est dans l'hémicycle on a des des
casiers dans nos pupitres wii ce titre
s'ouvre et maintenant on s'approvisionne
parfois avant de rentrer en science
quand les séance s'annonce longue on a
quelques quelques friandises cachés dans
nos pépites qui nous permet de tenir le
coup quand vous y passer trois heures
quatre heures d'affilée je pouvais dire
que parfois vous avez faim ou soif donc
donc soit il faut sortir soit il faut le
faire discrètement et pente est discrète
c'est interdit le normand il est
violemment modéré quand ils me forcent
des fois à voter oui ou à voter non
enfin voter pour ou contre parce que je
serais trop tenté assez souvent de
m'abstenir en disant il ya des choses
qui vont bien il ya des choses que l'on
va bien dans ce texte donc je fais
d'entre eux deux c'est l'abstention j'ai
mes vaches sur sur sur mon téléphone ont
montré nous c'est mes vaches ses veaux
vaches que vous surveillez voilà ça
m'arrive dans les mystiques de regarder
les premières interventions j'étais
vraiment je pense que j'ai tremblé
énormément pour sortir à la raison où
est la limite parfois
ça m'arrive de prendre un car de cars de
bêtabloquants vraiment je sens une
intervention est importante et c'est
handicapant un certain moment ça peut
être handicapant
j'ai beaucoup voyagé dans l'hémicycle en
fonction des différentes majorités donc
voilà alors vous vous êtes à la donc je
suis ici voilà ça c'est votre place vous
voyez davantage si vous voulez d'être le
long des micros c'est que quand vous
intervenez vous vous levez vous premier
micro tout de suite ses malheurs on
dirait un chanteur de charme la façon
dont vous prenez le que le micro il faut
cracher dans le micro pour être entendu
il faut cracher avait il faut être comme
ça c'est vrai à oui mais la façon dont
voulons poignée cpa c'est oui oui parce
que on sent que vous avez l'habitude
d'un
parce que ils finissent par se dégrader
mais ça s'abîme
ouais mais ça souple mais c'est quand
même mal traités par les députés bah oui
parce que vous avez des gens excités qui
s'est pas johnny mais les palois alors
montrez nous votre tablette voyez vous
ouvrez et vous avez le pour le contre et
l'abstention c'est très rapide 1 vous
avez quelques secondes car cinq secondes
ça s'allume ça défile et quand vous
appuyez sur un bouton ça s'arrête vrai
et donc vous pouvez refaire mais quand
vous êtes assis quand vous êtes à six
mois ça va si vous voulez mais les
grands gaillards ils ont les joues comme
ça et décret est donc ici vous basculez
puis vous avez une petite la great ça
évite que les dossiers tombe et puis là
vous avez à l'intérieur arie alors ça
c'est pour les billets doux ce qu'on
appelle c'est à dire que quand on
s'ennuie on écrit des trucs aux
ministres où j'ai saisi ce ministre ou
est-ce qu'on en ait de tels dossiers de
saisies vous le mettez vous mettez
demande du ministre était dans une
enveloppe ça fait sa devise à evian lui
des huissiers ils sont là donc ils vous
voient qu'ils viennent vous me donnez et
c'est pas plus simple de lui envoyer un
sms sominice il est interdit de
téléphoner et même d'avoir son téléphone
non pas d'avoir mes mais alors ils ont
mis des brouilleurs certains moments bon
d'accord on a eu les
voiliers gens qui sont comme ça en
permanence et ça parce qu'on en fait
beaucoup qui a essuyé sa tout énormément
sa truite c'est la maladie du député
scellés et puis d'ailleurs moi je
demande toujours aux collègues montre
moi tes pouces alors quand il des gars
qu'on des pousses comme ça avec toute la
journée mais finissait par avoir des
poules comme ça j'ai jamais remarqué
voyez moi j'ai dépouilles sont
relativement fin vous twittez peu à part
alors la tablette par contre que ça
ferme paquet mais c'est là que à
l'intérieur donc vos collègues députés
car j ai
dit qu'est ce que c'est que ça des
crêpes suzette vous prenez un café enfin
des jeunes et je vais droit un petit
requin taupe elle les amène
[Musique]
vous êtes pro demande le député qui
connaît le mieux l'hémicycle j'ai de
passer tellement d'heures et mon compère
sa plaque est là
parce que votre grand père était député
mon grand-père était des boutiques et
c'est l'un des deux compagnons de la
libération
de la chambre de 36 il n'y a eu que deux
députés tous les deux à titre posthume
pour voulait ainsi que c'est une affaire
de famille un peu de celui du côté de ma
mère ils ont été parlementaires de 1789
en 1958 vous deviez d'être là un peu
mais on peut se poser la question vos
enfants je suis un vieux célibataire
sans enfant
merci pour la visite je vous en prie
merci beaucoup monsieur de courson
s'était elle est très agréable journée
merci à vous solène ça va aller
non
bonjour non
ça va bien ça va très bien on est maire
vous êtes chargé voulez que je vous aide
et je veux bien
d'accord comme de nuit prendre nuit
trains de nuit ah oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai que vous votre circonscription est
loin de paris et dewey elle est en
ariège en ariège donc c'est des heures
et des heures de train 10 heures une
dizaine d'heures et vous arrivez vous
êtes chargé comme ça à chaque fois je
suis pas très bien organisée
la gare d'austerlitz de la gare
d'austerlitz d'accord et alors là
c'est votre bureau donc de bon matin
vous arrivez comme ça et voilà donc
voila nous permet à la rue mais moi je
suis père c'est gentil d'autres on est
on est là voilà comment on vole pas les
bonbons jour cela et puis là on a des
invalides l'a donc avec des manifs on
s'en va vite vous les voyez dans les
temps mais vous vous avez ou devant des
lamas d'accord à dépendre si j'ai le
temps mais sinon il ya des manifestants
qu'on va voir mais donc pas d'accord il
ya un tunnel un tunnel secret plus ou
moins secrets fait sombrer cette ronde
qui passe du palais bourbon jusqu'ici
cette route je suis passé voilà sous la
chaussée mais pour être honnête j'ai mis
un peu de temps il trouvé
d'accord bien peu de talent alors le
tunnel il sert à quoi il sert à protéger
les députés s'il se passe quelque chose
dehors ou à 18 ans gagner du temps aussi
pas se mouiller et quand il pleut
d'accord voilà
monsieur millon bonjour comment ça va
c'est naïve ou super alors c'est dans
votre bureau bienvenus
c'était des chambres d'hôtel c'est tout
à fait en fait c'est ça faisait partie
du du bâtiment qui était un ancien hôtel
et qui a été totalement réaménagé pour y
faire des bureaux un jupon à visualiser
alors
on exactement on et voilà c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal c'est sans fin après il
faut savoir trier les lieux un voila
voila c'est à dire que moi j'ai un
timide on moi j'ai besoin voilà deux
d'avoir mes éléments d'avoir un bout de
chez moi un bout de voile à un bout de
ma vie sur le bureau et c'est le plus
important et là on a le fameux lit le à
nos lits pliants dépliant wada corps et
donc c'est assez spartiate mais c'est
très pratique je l avouer que quand on
rentre de séance demi il faut se coucher
rapidement on n'a pas cette impression
de finalement de toujours en train de
travailler c'est à dire on va s'y enfin
je veux dire par une école de quoi et
quand je suis allongé richard ferrand
qu'il y avait de
la tension
mais voilà parfois ça vous arrive de
dire j'ai oublié porter le projet de loi
et hop
ça m'arrive souvent et ça me paraît en
pleine nuit ah oui ça m'est arrivé hier
soir j'ai l'âge et la commission mixte
paritaire quand il faut que je mette ça
et donc du coup je me suis relevé et
malheureusement qu'on me voit pas parce
que fut en caleçon et et je recycle
député peut travailler en qu'elles sont
mais ça arrive c'est bon je vous laisse
beaucoup les jeux tu as les divisions je
suis choquée qu'ils avaient le droit de
faire le ça vous embête pas mais non
voyons alors voilà c'est ça quand même
ah oui c'est bien c'est bien oui ça
donne envie d'être député si vous êtes
avions envie d'être député qui pour
levis arrêt s'est pas passé comme
ça c'est votre la fameuse salle de bains
maximino dont donc mon devoir
allez identique à tous les
parlementaires qui ont un bureau ici au
vent marin je vais vous montrer j'ai
plein de jeunes créent
donc c'est à découvrir à l'espace visage
las et le gel douche là c'est juste
espace visage ah oui quand je vais dans
les hôtels j'aime bien prendre
bien sûr mais j'aime bien changer de
crem toute embauche un peu indiqué tout
ça alors je vois le soin belle gueule
oui alors ça c'est génial ses succès en
ce moment là il ya une différence
selon les jours selon des projets de loi
après
l'hiver on peut aussi mettre le soin
bonne mine parce que certains un peu la
peau et ça fait genre en enfants le soir
je vais mettre un peu de la de crème
nourrissante occupant tous voila c'est
quoi la crème nourrissante euros du bon
là il paraît que satan la peau
vous êtes très jeune oui mais il paraît
qu'il faut mettre de la crème anti rides
et 25 ans pour qu'elle soit si vous avez
35 34 producteurs d'ici vous voyez je
vous donne
de ce soir d'autres termes non oui ça
m'arrive ça m'arrive quand il ya une
grosse mise et là on fait appel au frigo
où j'avais la hauteur de caisse cadum
frigoulet là on allait les patchs en
6ème
lassé des patchs alors alors attendez il
ya de l'eau là dedans comme ça le soir
quand vous rentrez de ces enjeux ni par
vous mettez ça saoule et et à plein mais
je n'ai pas de terme génial il raconte
ça se garde au frais ah bah oui c'est
mieux d'en fait tout ce qu'il ya les
faits donc ça c'est un secret tu députés
pour le prémice à la peau de gens qui
savent vraiment d'exclure parce que je
ne suis pas du bluff mais pas de chance
on
venez je vais vous montrer on a on a on
a fait des apéros alors parce que le
costume cravate regardez ce que vos
collègues pensent je préfère évidemment
ne pas avoir de cravates qu'avoir une
cravate mal mise pour des gens de ma
génération c'est un peu déconcertant
mais je suis un vieux con le costard
pour le coup c'est un bleu rpr ça on
peut dire les choses en fait c'est du
costume qui cache à peu près la
personnalité voyez pas ce que la vérité
c'est que une apparence de discipline
avec des rayures sur le costume adams et
je peux vous assurer que dans ma
personnalité dans mes sports dans ma vie
quotidienne la discipline est un truc
contre lequel je me bats depuis depuis
mon plus jeune âge donc finalement c'est
pas vous en faites pas ça m'emmerde au
plus haut point de porter une cravate
moi je suis très attaché la cravate
jamais vous me verrez rentrer dans
l'hémicycle sans cravate pour moi c
c'est inenvisageable une fois ça m'est
arrivé parce que je courais immergé
panique travail et on a la chance
d'avoir les huissiers qui ont des
cravates dans leurs tiroirs et que du
coup j'ai mis une cravate pour pénétrer
dans l'hémicycle mais pour moi je suis
très attaché aux valeurs et la cravate
c'est quand même la moindre des choses
regardez ce que vos collègues députés
femmes disent du tailleur invest orange
j'ai mon sac mon sac orange et j'ai mes
chaussures oranges choyés d'ailleurs mes
collègues du moderne n'ont remarqué ce
matin ils m'ont même proposé de venir à
leur table ronde et véronique à mes
cochons roses c'est mes collègues
socialistes c'est qu'ils peuvent le dire
le vendredi va est un peu plus cool le
mardi questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
tout le monde réunis dans l'hémicycle
là on va être un petit peu plus enclins
à mettre un tailleur je trouve que vous
regardez pas assez est ce que vous
verrez que j'ai toujours le même
perfecto la même veste orange est là
mais ça tourne c'est à dire qu'il faut
quand même laver les vêtements c'est ça
après chacun là aussi très comique ça
j'assume j'aime j'aime
un certain style vestimentaire
pensions est ce que le tailleur et de
droite
je crois pas parce qu'il m'arrive d'en
porter comme il m'arrive de porter des
jeans c'est pour ça que c'est bien
d'être leur marche c'est en même temps
si tu envie de m'étendre du linky on est
en chine cette envie d'être en tailleur
très strictes tu veux le faire bientôt
plus partagée pour moi la chine dans
l'hémicycle c'est j'ai juste impensable
impensable ah oui comme comme quand je
vois des femmes qui c'est tout bête mais
pour une période vous pouviez pas
pénétrer dans l'hémicycle on est une
femme si vous aviez les épaules
découvertes aujourd'hui quand on voit
même une liste de la république venir en
débardeur enfin moi ça m'a juste choqué
ça vous arrive de d'être en jean et en
jamais jamais ça c'est pas possible j'en
ai pas dans la garde-robe
[Rires]
m
bonjour monsieur chiche bougeant bonjour
alors ici nous sommes dans la serre de
l'assemblée nationale hier à l'assemblée
diane serre des jardins un jardin des
aromates à côté on fait pousser du
basilic du valat de la vente et qui
poussent pas dans n'importe quelles
conditions on désherbe manuellement à la
binette concert de matériel électrique
c'est évidemment une logique de zéro
phyto et on est sur du circuit plus
court parce qu'on est d'ici ou du jardin
des arts ou de maths jusqu'aux cuisines
quitterait quant à côté pourquoi on ne
fait pas pousser à ce moment là vraiment
des légumes il s'agit à présent dit il
n'y a pas de congés j'en ai pas vus et
vous savez on est au palais bourbon dans
le 7e arrondissement de paris l'espace
est relativement restreint elle sait pas
si on va vous permettre de planter des
arbres fruitiers ou alors faire des
potagers dans les jardins de l'assemblée
mais il faut poser la question mais moi
voyez je ne savais pas du tout cas
l'assemblée poussait tant de choses il
ya des projets de loi qui prouve s'il ya
des idées qui pose mais je ne savais pas
qu'il y avait des aromates des arbustes
des arbres qu'on tous les députés ou
mais souvent à courir à subir ou à créer
l'actualité des actualités qui
s'enchaînent quand on fait du jardinage
il faut respecter le temps de pouce
l'instant l'on savoure place dans la
véritable temporalité des saisons
complètement et dans le respect d'un
rythme naturel celui de la planète le
temps du légume est donc le temps du
parlementaire et court le temps du
parlementaire on va dire l'activité du
parlementaire est très dynamique et ça
nous empêche
de temps en temps de prendre du recul
nous prendre de la hauteur sur certains
sujets
[Musique]
ah ah
voilà un beau symbole quand même vous
diront
on est tourné l'année on en profite
quand même mois aux herbes folles et
alors ça faisait des siennes propres
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour monsieur rare aux
honduriens venu vous êtes le gourmand
gourmet gastronomes parmi les députés
numéro un le plus le plus le plus
célèbre pour sa voyez il ya toujours
beaucoup de choses ici faites-nous voire
vous dans votre petit cachet de secret
les choses qui vont bien à boire à
manger manger des moules et comme
beaucoup nous racontant manger n'est pas
l'appareil à raclette afin de on a pas
mais on a des bonnes adresses il ya le
café des ministères sa bouche est la
reine incroyable donc là on est juste à
deux pas on sait l'effet livrer un petit
bourguignon une blanquette devant vous
prenez comme le temps de manger mais il
ya beaucoup de vos collègues c'est
effectivement un sandwich et un kebab
quelque chose s'est vite fait pour toi
pour s'embarrasse pas avec ça et
pourtant la cuisine c'est très important
dans la vie de beaucoup de vos collègues
regardez
il faut des e il faut mettre les oeufs
la veille ou l'avant veille avec les
truffes déjà la truffe parfume les oeufs
et vous avez déjà gagné 20 ou 30% de
deux d'arômes il nous est arrivé de dans
un petit moment de déprime d'avoir
toujours un petit stock au restaurant du
viiie et et nous fait une petite
omelette aux truffes ah c'est vrai voilà
il faut pas le dire pourquoi ne dit rien
au fond c'est le truc qui colle aux
doigts d'or et je mange de la viande
parce que un bon assad aux argentins ça
je peux pas dire non alors les ados
c'est quoi ces ados c'est le barbecue
vous êtes viande à redon
c'est un sujet très sérieux
est ce qu'il faut la percée avant la
cuisson
absolument pas c'est un crime 6
comme vous l'accusez à l'eau si vous la
percée elle perd tout son arôme qu'il
faut la cuire la démarrer à l'eau froide
20 minutes avec de la cancoillotte
chaudes et des pommes de terre c'est ça
me fait coiffer des plats ou masala
exactement je les maras des dalles fin
c'est quoi votre plat favori il ya un
truc que moi j'avais beaucoup cet égard
il ya la frénésie qui est un curry
calais bout avec beaucoup de non j'adore
les oignons j'aime bien utiliser des
techniques françaises mais avec des
ingrédients d'ailleurs c'est à dire donc
par exemple faire une crème brûlée à la
citronnelle à je vais utiliser du
basilic thaï au lieu d'utiliser du
basilic italiens par exemple ma
grand-mère faisait aussi des excellentes
crêpes avec la vie la particularité car
elle avait une poêle qui faisait des
comme des petites alvéoles en fait sur
les crèmes et c'était un peu sa
signature sur une scène carabine chez
une sorte de demou cela qu'on mange avec
des mamours les petits biscuits fins et
très très bon alors on s'aperçoit très
bon pour les coronaires mais c'est très
bon pour le moral ça vous aimez bien
ouais ouais tout ça il faut les manger
un excès c'est comme les frites
fessée c'est la dernière bouchée quand
on ne peut plus qu'elle a mais c'est
très intéressant c'est ce qu'on a vu là
c'est une france qui est forte sur sa
cuisine capable d'intégrer les cuisines
qui viennent d'ailleurs ça veut dire que
dans les problèmes qu'on a en ce moment
et vous voyez bien avec l'immigration et
bien c'est parce qu'on a eu des cuisines
forte une cuisine forte qu'elle a
intégré des choses différentiel c'est à
dire la tomate tout ça ça vient du pérou
on est capable d'assimiler des produits
qui viennent d'ailleurs et les députés
le nekrif très très bien c'est ça la
france vous avez des collègues députés
parfois qui je passe la porte du bureau
l'aïe qui se disent ya peut être un
petit truc à déguster ou pas il vient de
m'apporter des produits tous
richard j'ai découvert quelque chose
alors vous avez quoi des tripes des
andouilles écrit ces andouilles des
coûts d'un blanc au bout d'un barreau
gars qu'on croyait darko quoi y avait de
la bricole pas y être parce qu'il y en a
certains que d'aller il ya un côté
traversée de paris un peu la ja on
s'apporte des gens bond c'est exactement
ça quand la pression retombe et ben
c'est autour d'un petit verre autour de
quelque chose qui se venge chocolat vous
tente voilà amandine venez manger
jusqu'à maintenant journée obligé parce
que amandine est scellé chocolat c'est
obligé
oh la la c'est raffiné c ou c
j'ai bien fait je n'ai jamais toute la
journée
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bourlanges
bonjour je parle pas trop fort parce
qu'ici nous sommes dans la bibliothèque
de l'assemblée nationale alors il faut
pas parler trop fort mais je suis pas
très surpris de vous retrouver ici
écoutez c'est un bel endroit de rêve
dans ce bel endroit de l'assemblée
nationale on est entouré du savoir
politique de toute la france depuis des
siècles et je crois qu'on a plaisir à
y séjourner pour réfléchir lire
travailler regardez la hauteur de c2c
rayonna ça vous arrive de coûts vont
marcher sur des courses et non non moi
je ne sais même pas si on est autorisé à
le faire vrai il ya un petit côté harry
potter aussi un bon c'est un décor est
ce que vous entendez par là que les
enfants ne sont que les députés sont des
enfants ou des magiciens ah bah j'espère
un peu d'aidé nous
[Musique]
on peut vous voir comme ça souvent venir
qu'on lui c'est le plus souvent
j'emprunte les livres un livre que j'ai
emprunté et que je ne retrouve plus et
je vis en la culpabilité du prévenu l'a
la bibliothèque mais je suis sûr que je
le retrouverai parce que je n'ai pas
perdu gelée simplement comme on disait
quand j'étais à la cour des comptes a
dit ray 3d chez vous de ces racailles
rien les chômeurs il est quelque part
[Musique]
il faut dire qu'il ya vraiment des
trésors dans cette bibliothèque elle est
connue pour ça d'ailleurs alors vous la
caisse que vous avez un joli et je
regarde c'est l'esprit des lois de
montesquieu et c'en est le tome premier
et c'est quand même une des grandes
contributions historiques d'un auteur
français la france à l'évolution du
droit public moderne c'est une c'est une
très très grande oeuvre si je pouvais
faire en sorte que tout le monde de
nouvelles raisons pour aimer c'est de
voir son prince sa patrie
ces lois qu'on puisse mieux sentir son
bonheur dans chaque pays et dans chaque
gouvernement dans chaque poste où l'on
se trouve
je me croirais le plus heureux des
mortels
à la fin de la préface du thomas oui ça
le sann allure
ya une forme de poésie dans le sait très
bien décrit également il n'est pas
indifférent que le peuple souhaite
éclairer les préjugés des magistrats ont
commencé par être les préjugés de la
nation dans un tant d'ignorance on
n'aura aucun doute même lorsqu'on fait
les plus grands beaux dans un camp de
lumière on tremble encore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour monsieur baladant là bonjour
alors ici on est à la dans la salle de
cinéma de l'assemblée une petite synthe
que c'est une belle salle c'est très
jeune il allait bel lequel sert en
réalité à diffuser des films pour les
personnes qui viennent visiter
l'assemblée qui explique l'assemblée son
rôle dans la constitution qui a voilà
ces pédagogies pédagogique et elle
permet aussi aux députés de montrer un
certain nombre de films par rapport aux
projets sur lesquels il travaille c'est
marrant je trouve que qu'il existe une
salle comme ça et ça paraît logique
parce que l'assemblée c'est une petite
ville en fait il ya un bureau de poste
il ya un salon de coiffure il ya un
appareil pour cirer ses chaussures il ya
un distributeur bancaire et ça des gens
ne savent pas forcément en réalité c'est
pas c'est pas du luxe c'est pas des
privilèges et un parlementaire qui vient
du lundi au jeudi qui est loin de chez
lui c'est logique qu'ils puissent
trouver un certain nombre de commodités
qui permettent de faire son travail
sérieusement quoi vous êtes député
maintenant mais vous continuez à faire
de la photo et notamment comme c'est
devenu maintenant finalement c'est comme
un peu comme un hobby vous en faites mai
à l'assemblée ouais alors j'en fais en
réalité très peu à l'assemblée ouais en
fait très peu à l'assemblée pour une
bonne et simple raison c'est ce que ça
c'est interdit c'est interdit mais vous
vous avez le droit parce que vous êtes
député non vous n'êtes pas le droit non
c'est interdire tous les députés ah oui
les huissiers viennent nous rappeler à
l'ordre elles sont très belles vos
photos on en envoie une la whey alors là
c'est mon amie sarah est là éric était à
l'époque député qui est maintenant
ministre reconnaît monsieur bourlanges
valencia monsieur tessier à douala et
monsieur ait et devant voilà elle donne
l'impression qu'on s'amuse aussi qu'on
peut donner le vérifier et ça vous
n'avez pas le droit de le faire c'est un
terrain est interdite ouais donc là on
n'est pas prêt bassi parce que bon voilà
allez un peu voyou la lettre voyous
savez quand on n'a pas le droit on prend
la gauche alors celle là c'est une
interruption de séance c'est un moment
de discussion sur qu'est ce qu'on fait
et pendant ce pendant ce temps-là
héritière il est au téléphone avec
matignon et je trouve que voilà elle est
vraiment c'est vraiment un moment
d'histoire il faut quand même qu'ils
aient un député photographe et
réalisateur qui de l'intérieur puis cela
fout oui oui mais vous auriez envie de
faire pourquoi pas un film permet moi
j'adorerais ça serait bien mais
j'adorerais faire un fil où justement
les caméras pourraient rentrer dans les
travées et je suis sûr qu'on pourrait
faire en sorte qu'elle se voit pas mais
ça troublerait et c'est pour ça que ça
se fera jamais parce que quelque part
vous voyez vous savez dès qu'il ya une
caméra le monde change alors les
parlementaires qu'ils ont des passions
des hobbies ouais donc sert pour
certains ça va être la photo le cinéma
la brocante etc regardez ce que vos
conneries avec des curieux ça va
comme passion vrai j'adore la brocante
la broncho alors l'avantagé c'est que je
peux en plus concilier ça avec mes
activités de parlementaires donc bien
aidé parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
vieilleries à l'assemblée basque il ya
beaucoup de manifestations locales a
compris et alors qu'est ce que vous
aimez particulièrement j'avais fait une
petite fixation sur les tableaux de
fleurs natures mortes voilà mais après
je suis fan d'assiettes de verre enfin
je sache que des choses un peu de mamie
quand même un global - mais je dois être
très mamie moi je suis un fan de niki de
saint phalle donc j'ai sculpté des crous
nana avec des formes généreuses vous
fait ça pour vous détendre c'est un peu
un jardin secret en fait ça me fait du
bien ça y va dès lors ce moment je suis
en rien la république est donc selena
n'a que je peins camp bleu blanc rouge
j'ai des déguisements tortues ninja ge
des déguisements de pinocchio j'ai des
déguisements de dracula j'ai beaucoup
vraiment beaucoup de déguisements je
n'aimais pas pour voilà l'assemblée
nationale si vous l'invitez chez vous
pour halloween pour une ferme bal
costumé pour votre anniversaire pour le
nouvel an et je lis et de grandes
chances que je me dis ça c'est des
personnages
des personnages un peu de rock tels
comme ça avec la guitare ou dans ma
jeunesse j'étais très punk rock
j'aimais beaucoup les groupes de femmes
en fait à mais c'est vrai que voilà je
crois que là mon histoire des petits
dessins aussi c'est une façon de décès
de retrouver un peu d'art dans ma vie
quotidienne d'un moment ça me manque
vous saviez que vous collectez passion à
ce point non mais là je vois j'imaginais
mais je découvre certaines personnes que
je connais bien par ailleurs je trouve
que ça ça nous humaniser c'est important
parce que parfois les gens ont
l'impression qu'on est des
extraterrestes un peu froid moi je pense
qu'on est tout le contraire au contraire
on est des étaient vraies éponges
émotionnel et de sensibilités et les
parlementaires enfin la plupart donc je
trouve que c'est bien épicée veulent
c'est bien le montrer moi j'ai une
conviction c'est qu'un homme ou une
femme politique qui a du talent et
quelqu'un qui a une capacité à créer
députés on est on écrit la loi on écrit
la loi dès qu'on l'a créée on l'a on les
fait sortir du néant voilà et donc ça ça
se fait pas comme ça que sur la
technique ça se fait aussi par la
sensibilité et l'âme humaine faut savoir
est aussi être capable de faire le pas
de côté parce que on aurait tendance
aussi d'être très conservateur sur la
loi et dire mais non mais on pourrait
écrire ça différemment il faut être
imaginatif en politique il faut parfois
être aussi un peu rêveur utopiste ça me
semble être important eh bien monsieur
balanant merci beaucoup merci à vous et
bravo pour ce que vous faites ça permet
de voir le
et l'assemblée sous un autre regard et
c'est important eh bien c'était un
plaisir de vous avoir aussi bonne
journée
où
bonjour patrick vignal bonjour camille
alors ici on n'est pas exactement dans
la salle de sport de l'assemblée mais
vous vous êtes député est prof de judo
je suis professeur de judo et député ce
qui est marrant c'est que il ya beaucoup
de députés qui font du sport et pour qui
c'est une passion qui leur sert on
dirait dans leur action politique c'est
à dire qu'on dirait que ça une influence
sur leur façon d'envisager les rapports
en politique vous savez le sport c'est
de la célébration collective vous
imaginez dans des stades le chirurgien
dentiste chefs d'entreprise et le petit
jeune de quartier le même amour du
maillot alors vos collègues députés ils
s'intéressent au sport regarder un peu
ce qu'ils ont ce qu'ils nous ont dit sur
les sports il ya la salle alors que moi
j'appelle la salle benalla parce que au
moment de la sphère benalla il avait
déjà une carte à l'assemblée pour
pouvoir rentrer dans cette salle là
alors moi je ne lui ai jamais vu c'est
dans un sous-sol une salle dans laquelle
vous trouvez à peu près tout ce qu'il
faut pour se faire mal des appareils de
musculation des tapis de course j'ai un
sac de boxe à la maison aussi ça pour me
détendre c'est pas mal
aucun car c'est une équipe vraiment
parlementaire c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
avoir des pouvoirs françois ruffin qui
est à droite et c'est exactement ça il
est il est milieu droit
voilà j'ai mes petites briques immobel
stern d'accord
need you gave était une musique que non
non pas forcément temps forcément non il
m'arrive de faire des trucs de
renforcement en écoutant même enceinte
est
terrible mais donc on n'est plus dans le
truc un peu de gym en fait voilà moi je
fais 11 km le marbre ouais comme le
téléphone on sait mais met donc je
marchais dans ma vie
entre les salles des commissions les
salles l'hémicycle les différents
rendez-vous qu'on a d'abord on va
regarder la météo avant de s'embarquer
sur un bateau regardez la météo c'est
voir là je dirai comment se comporte la
société comme alhaji comment elle et
qu'est ce que les gens attendent ensuite
on va surfer quand même sur les micros
les vents les vents contraires après il
faut il faut prendre une option et
l'assumé en fait on doit pas regarder
l'obstacle au cheval si on veut sauter
correctement doit regarder plus loin
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des coups de
cravache en fait le coup de cravache il
doit être donnée au bon moment donc
souvent politiques ont deux voilà on a
on entend des choses tellement
contradictoires me donne des ordres
contradictoires et pareil que pour un
choix il comprend rien donc et s'énerve
et hop ça donne un coup de cul commencé
alors le support le sport et le sport et
la politique ça vous évoque quoi briller
dans tous les sens du terme et le judo
c'est un art de vivre c'est un code
moral et c'est un priorité l'humilité
c'est à dire que vous perdez un combat
larbitre ne vous a pas donné raison et
vous pensez même que l' arbitre
avantages et l'autre vous allez quand
même le saluer quand quelqu'un est
violent contre vous vous amener une
situation pour qu'elle puisse un petit
peu se décompresser démonstration si
vous voulez
le judo c'est l'art de l'esquivé
perdrait souplesse et s'y adapter sa au
combat politique on serait pas toujours
un rivalité en confrontation savez ce
qu'on dit des combats de coqs
c'est d'ailleurs très souvent chez la
gente masculine
le combat de coqs ça ne sert à rien de
sortir les muscles vous esquivez passé
de suite devant prenez mon bras et
faites moi chanter
[Musique]
mon projet de loi et le pont projet de
loi
et moi je pense que non
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé là vous
m'avez montré en fait que le rapport de
force souvent n'était pas la principale
qualité qu'il fallait avoir un judo
c'est cela qu'on veut changer si on est
en action tous les deux mois vous avez
posé nos mères là je me dis donc qu'est
ce qui peut me faire comment je vais
esquivé comment je vais anticipé comment
il va accompagner mon travail de jus
d'honneur
[Musique]
alors on fait moins rigolo la
fois trop confiance en vous regardez ce
qui peut vous arriver c'est que la wii
si vous continuez je vous agace l'avant
bras alors il faut que vous frappiez
[Rires]
j'ai encore besoin bras pour voter ah si
vous votez c'est différent si vous votez
pour nous c'est encore
[Musique]
vous n'utilisez pas le salon coiffure de
l'assemblée vous d'habitude nous qui je
crois il existe depuis très longtemps
c'est très très très ancien de salons de
coiffure de l'assemblée et qui faisait
partie de la tradition parce qu'on
estimait que le député se devait d'être
toujours élégant et puis qui n'avait pas
toujours le temps en plus ça c'est sûr
voilà on va y aller comme les collines
pour les députés c'est important la
coiffure à jour j'étais avec l'éphémère
sur un terreau d'état madame delaunay
minimes monsieur de courson vous avez
une moumoute
et je lui dis non madame la milice chez
moi tout est naturel alors elle s'empare
de cheveux elle dira belgique se doit ça
s'appelle une coupe à la garçonne mais
qui quand même une point de vue du tarif
est un pari fou de femmes ah oui c'est
une inégalité quand même assez
effrayante mais vous avez eu les cheveux
beaucoup plus long j'ai eu car
évidemment parce qu'on passe pas tout de
suite et puis après
mais à 25 ans j'avais déjà cette coupe
donc ne pas trop changer je trouve que
ça d'abord jeu sans doute syndic une
forme de stabilité politique sur le fond
et puis que ce soit pas ça le sujet de
commentaires en fait le complexe qu'on
pouvait avoir barthez finalement il a
sublimé tout ça quoi c'était la star il
était sauve son crâne faisait l'objet de
toutes les convoitises
jean que d'envoi la ville se pense que
je pense que martel a beaucoup fait pour
les uns comme l'épouvantail a fait des
choses avec cette magnifique cris
n'avait non c'est pas beau là il faut
s'attacher les cheveux il faut alors
j'étais est de 2
de la tenue mais ça me ressemble pas
mais j'attache et les cheveux tu vois ça
donne quoi martin tout seul et c'est
magnifique
payton de dalifort et voilà c'est mieux
ça fait plus députés eh bien il paraît
j'ai deux épis montrez-nous
[Musique]
g2g pi et je trouve plus facile de la
faire à gauche que la faire à droite
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec vos points
de vue politiques pour se nourrir à vous
de rayer une récente rissala boris
garçons voilà villani il a il a une
vraie centriste mais c'est très rare
parce que c'est sa date de
l'entre-deux-guerres quoi ça par exemple
c'est bien alors ah bah on fait comme
d'habitude la raie au milieu
comme vous le sentez parce que vous avez
l'art est à droite ça a été un peu
variable mais ouais j'ai ensuite
légèrement à droite un point mais après
je après oui
voilà un peu façon beatles sont d'accord
beatles début d'année début de notre
santé
moi je les trouve très très bien comme
ça
ça c'est bien
voilà vous êtes content le résultat est
bien ça me faisait bien bravo à l'eau je
m'étais aussi bien coiffés à aa
[Musique]
là on peut dire que la politique - ya
plusieurs courants dans votre groupe
est en
mouvement est ce que le rock est de
gauche
qui donne le rythme aujourd'hui c'est la
france en semi-finale
à la fois le tempo et le texte ses pieds
basse
ouais ouais mais il va dire que la base
est en marche et médecins de majorité
fait le melody on écrit la partie si on
sait dire que la musique elle est
capable d'apaiser un peu le sens de
débats où la nature un peu virulente de
nos débats au parfois l'émouvant un peu
trop loin d'où qu'ils viennent écoutez
c'est la contribution de la musique au
débat public voilà et donc c'est très
bien ainsi parce que ça apprend à
s'écouter aussi la musique non ça
apprend à écouter de rythme de l'autre
de jouer avec quand on joue en groupe
oui quand on joue en contre bas quand on
est en solo et des pleins de partitions
différentes à une part groupe
des fois c'est un peu la catégorie à des
groupes comme le nôtre il ya plusieurs
partitions dans le même groupe heures
quand même beaucoup laitière
a rejoint harmonie ça marcherait pas du
côté d' en marche vous avez aussi un
groupe il ya ils ont un gros groupe ils
sont 300
[Rires]
il ya beaucoup de députés qui sont fans
de musique je voudrais juste vous faire
réagir sur une petite vidéo
j'aime bien mais que j'aime bien mettre
guina turner
c'est cette façon qu'elle avait de se
poser qui était je trouvais sympathique
où et c'est ça un peu la femme la
famille ont quoi ainsi moi je prie pour
que tu fus mon exil qu'est ce qui nous
plaît chez farmer la sensibilité la
poésie
ça étonne souvent encore jeudi mylène
farmer effectivement maintenant plus
avoir du hard rock ou des choses comme
ça oui et non moi j'aime les artistes
quand il dénonce mais c'est pas les
artistes qui a porté solution c'est le
politique qui apporte les solutions is
artistes de gauche peuvent dénoncer ce
qui est un vrai problème et on peut
proposer des solutions de droite le
souvenir de supertramp c'était je n'ai
vu à bercy et ça ça restera un souvenir
extraordinaire le concert démarre et
n'arrive saxo marseillaise est juste
merci la france leur a peut être de
droite je pense qu'il est arabe de droit
à toi moi je suis absent et familiales
voilà
et vous il faut le signaler vous avez
représenté la france à l'eurovision oui
oui en 87 c'était une belle aventure
k
m
parfois ça passe mieux le message quand
on chante que quand on parle et à la
flambée évidemment j'apprécie pouvoir
pouvoir continuer doral moi je sais que
peu importe l'heure on termine la séance
à l'assemblée j'ai toujours dans ma
valoches mois la petite enceinte
portable n'importe quelle heure du jour
ou de la nuit il ya de la musique qu il
est femme sadie parce qu'on va voter en
tout cas ça donne de l'énergie de
réfléchir ça donne l'énergie d'aller
plus loin ça donne beaucoup de choses
2006 1 je prends ta chambre en tout cas
moi je vous remercie d'avoir joué le jeu
et de nous offrir maintenant un moment
assez unique moi j'ai jamais vu ça des
députés de différentes tendances
politiques qui do the offre de la
musique ensemble même si beaucoup vous
écoute donc maintenant dont je rêvais
d'un autre monde
[Musique]
oh